speaking of reelection there is
something very unusual happening in the
Democratic primary Republican turned
Democrat Michael Bloomberg is instantly
polling 6% in one recent poll and an
average of 4% immediately surpassing
many candidates who have been in this
thing for six months a year even longer
the new poll in which Michael Bloomberg
is polling 6% is from the hill Michael
Bloomberg is of course the turbo
billionaire who is somewhere between 10
and 20 times richer than our current
billionaire president Donald Trump he
has actually shaken up the race if you
look at the polling with Bloomberg in
the race you see that in the polls in
which Bloomberg is included there are
currently five being used to calculate
Bloomberg's average of 4% you see that
Joe Biden's support is mostly unchanged
but both Elizabeth Warren and Bernie
Sanders support is down Tulsi Gabbard
has gone from polling one to three in
recent polls to polling just zero to two
Kamala Harris is polling as low as two
once you include Bloomberg despite
having been as high as five or six
percent in recent polls there are now
discussions that Kamala Harris may soon
be exiting this race altogether so let
me get all the normal disclaimers out of
the way I'm not supporting Michael
Bloomberg
I already got Heat yesterday merely by
pointing out that Pete Budaj edge has
been climbing in the polls people saying
David you're a Buddha judge
establishment shill I'm not supporting
Pete I'm not supporting Michael
Bloomberg I'm simply telling you the
numbers Michael Bloomberg is very
quickly having impact that many
candidates who have been in this thing
for six to twelve months have not been
able to make Duval Patrick when he got
into the race wanted to make at least
this level of impact has failed to do so
and Michael Bloomberg is doing it to a
degree now can he make the debates on
the one hand Bloomberg has until
December 12th to qualify on polling and
donor numbers right now it is only Biden
Sanders Warren Buddha judge Harris and
Klobuchar there are six people in the
next debate
if qualification closed today Tom Styer
would be out Tulsi Gabbard would be out
Andrew yang would be out Cory Booker and
Leon Castro would not make the next
debate and of course as of today neither
would Bloomberg or Deval Patrick
Bloomberg may easily end up qualifying
on polling the question is going to be
donors and I actually don't know the
answer to this Bloomberg is not even
accepting donations he's financing his
own campaign can he even make the debate
on that basis since there is a donor
requirement he may preclude himself from
even maybe qualifying because of that
he's been spending millions of dollars
on ads tons of our viewers have been
telling me they're regularly getting
Michael Bloomberg ads before our videos
on YouTube the debate itself scheduled
for December 19th so what does this mean
for Bloomberg we have no polling from
Iowa New Hampshire Nevada or South
Carolina yet that includes Michael
Bloomberg six percent nationally or four
percent nationally is not going to mean
much if he can't make any headway in any
of those first four primaries I see
Iowa as a very tough one for Michael
Bloomberg New Hampshire's may be more of
a possibility Nevada and South Carolina
are certainly question marks but imagine
being in this race for months and months
and then you see Bloomberg enter and now
you're instantly losing to him like if I
were working for Kamala Harris or Andrew
yang Amy Klobuchar a Cory Booker Tulsi
Gabbard who Leon Castro you just can't
seem to get past 1 to 3% in Harris's
case she actually was up to 11 or 12
percent at one point but has just fallen
apart and then you see Michael Bloomberg
come in and he's averaging 4% and
getting 6% in one poll I would be
extremely demoralized if I were the
candidates if I were working on their
campaigns I don't work on political
campaigns but that that's my sense of it
no doubt this is going to hugely
encourage Michael Bloomberg if he makes
that next debate I wouldn't be surprised
to see him get quite a bit of face time
merely for being able to get this level
of support in just a few weeks after
announcing this does not by the way seem
like a particularly fun time to be in
Elizabeth Warren supporter she has been
in free fall as I told you yesterday for
several weeks now with Michael Bloomberg
in and climbing
I can't imagine this is what Elizabeth
Warren and her supporters want to see
where will we be two weeks from now no
idea absolutely no idea this is a
primary that is very quickly taking on
some different dynamics to say the least
and I wouldn't be surprised if
everything reverses in the next two
weeks and we simply see Warren Bernie
Biden recover and be very clearly the
only people in frontrunner status or we
may see Buddha judge continue to climb
we may see Michael Bloomberg get more
traction I have no idea and of course
for Michael Bloomberg the possibility of
making that next debate if indeed it is
even a possibility given that he is
financing his own campaign will be a big
factor in how this thing plays out let
me know what you think we'll have a poll
on our Instagram page about this at
David Pakman show and while you're there
follow me on Instagram as well at David
Pakman privacy com is one of our
sponsors and they're giving you $5.00
just for using their free service at
privacy comm slash Pakman privacy's of
service I've been using for a while now
I love it it saves me a bunch of
headaches it's completely free and it's
very quick to set up and here's how it
works when you pay for something online
or over the phone instead of exposing
your real credit card number privacy
lets you generate virtual card numbers
the payments are withdrawn from your
checking account but your real card
number stays completely private and you
do it all with one click you can
autofill the card number in your web
browser on the phone you can create 12
virtual cards a month you can set
spending limits freeze them delete them
whenever you want I especially love it
for free trials where you need to give a
credit card number because I can destroy
the virtual card number as soon as I
give it to the company and I know I
won't be charged in the future if you're
ordering food over the phone why do I
need to give a restaurant my real card
number I don't have to companies don't
have to know who you are your real
credit card number is protected from the
data breaches that happen unfortunately
more often than we would like and it's
completely free they do have a paid
version with different tiers where you
can create more virtual credit card
numbers per month cash back rewards
extra security features but go ahead and
sign up for the free service it's a no
brainer companies can't charge you
unexpectedly you're protected from
identity theft that costs you nothing
and privacy is giving you $5.00 to spend
just for signing up when you go to
privacy comm slash Pakman